Matthew I'm worried I'm really worried
about you when you get out losing touch
with the world not knowing how things
work I've been in here five weeks yeah
and look at your phone no one uses
landlines anymore Abraham Lincoln we
have cell phones we text here I'll text
you should get that in the second
I run a cell phone in here then who did
I just text I don't I don't know fine
Moses will text your way the
old-fashioned way nothing is sup I'm in
prison I need you to get me out of here
okay
what is that it's an emoji boohoo I'm in
prison
boohoo I'm a cat this is how people who
aren't 300 communicate George Burns
you're gonna need to know emojis if
you're gonna communicate in 2014 the
hell is that me who knows but emoji sure
are fun they look like a Japanese girls
daydream it's not fun this is ludicrous
I need you to tell me but not it means
I'm typing usually means a text is
coming in except sometimes with my
girlfriend she'll start typing and then
she doesn't send one I'm like what the
family what's the look what are you
gonna say you start typing you fish okay
I don't need to know about texting I
need to know is that how is it sad that
was a dick was that a dick pic I was a
dick dick I didn't mean to send it to
you and I apologize I meant to send it
to a different man I'm done with this I
don't want any more dick pics
no more emojis okay none of this okay
just tell me about my case for God's
sake okay okay
we'll keep it about your case it duck
what is that is that more like Tex Lang
autocorrected and mess it up
I'm sorry I can't help you I'm sorry
what does that [ __ ] it's not ice cream